احمد هارون الذي عمل مساعدا للبشير وقبلها
وزيرا وواليا على كردفان قبل ايام هرب من
السجن مع قيادات اخرى من حكومه الرئيس
السوداني المخلوع عمر البشيره فمن هو احمد
هارون هو الشخصيه الاكثر جدلا في حكومه
البشير عام 2003 تم تعيينه وزير دوله
بوزاره الداخليه ومسؤولا عن مكتب دارفور
الامني في فتره كان فيها الصراع داميا في
اقليم دارفور الرجل اتهم بتورطه في جرائم
مرعبه ضد المدنيين لكنه انكر كل ذلك وانه
ليس هناك اي اثبات حول تلطقي يديه بدماء
الضحايا الابريه في دارفور المفارقه كانت
تعيينه وزير دوله للشؤون الانسانيه عام
2005 حتى ان المدعي العام للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ريس اوكامبو ووصف تعيينه
بهذا المنصب انذاك بالثعلب الذي عهد اليه
برعايه الدجاج معتبرا ان هارون والانسانيه
لا يجتمعان